[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue à tous dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires tout de suite voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce journal avec
elle à une des conséquences des tempêtes
qui ont touché le nord de la france
cette semaine des producteurs ont vu une
grande partie de leur culture impact est
une mauvaise nouvelle évidemment pour
leur chiffre d'affaires reportage de
votv à suivre dès le début de cette
émission le luxe s'implante à vendôme
dans le loir et cher la marque louis
vuitton vient d'inaugurer deux nouveaux
ateliers sur place pour l'occasion
bernard arnault lui même le pdg du
groupe lvmh et bruno le maire le
ministre de l'économie avait fait le
déplacement une visite qu'a suivi
christophe rigaud pour le grand jt des
territoires dans les vosges la
réouverture des dancing et des thés
dansants fait le bonheur des habitués le
retour sur les pistes après plusieurs
semaines de fermeture liée aux qu'ovide
comble également géant et musiciens
comme nous le montrera vosges télévision
des chevaux de trait en lieu et place de
camions c'est le pari tenté par enée 10
dans les yvelines que l'entreprise s'est
essayé à la traction animale pour
réaliser des opérations lourdes une
démarche respectueuse de l'environnement
reportage en fin de journal avec télé 78
dans les yvelines
et on débute donc ce journal avec les
conséquences malheureuses qui ont touché
le nord de la france il ya quelques
jours les vents violents mise à mal
notamment les productions de certains
maraîchers c'est le cas par exemple de
justin berthou installé en bio depuis
six ans dans le pas de calais la tempête
a mis à terre une nécessaire reportage
de caroline fichten gourou et aux tv la
chaîne du groupe la voix du nord sur
place
sulaimon templiers de sa soeur justine
berthou sauf ce qui peut encore l'être
les épinards les mesquins les oignons
nouveaux les légumes ne sont pas encore
à maturité au finiront par venir à cause
de l'humidité le passage de la tempête
pour la jeune paysanne installé en bio
depuis six ans a des conséquences
désastreuses
elle perce et sert de 300 mètres carrés
qui représente un quart de sa surface
couverte sous serre les serres
représente en elle-même 60 à 70% de son
chiffre d'affaires
là je vais perdre les cultures qui sont
dessous mais je peux pas enchaîner avec
les cultures qui que je devais faire
après et ça représente j'avais calculé
ne serait ce que pour
juste la structure et les cultures qui
sont là actuellement en dessous on est à
9500 euros de chiffre d'affaires de
perdue fin et 4500 euros de chiffre
d'affaires + la structure et si on
compte toutes les crises ou culture qui
a derrière qui devait suivre derrière on
est à plus de 17000 17 millions de
pertes quoi car les semis en préparation
comme ici ne pourront pas être mis en
terre ensuite s'en sert impossible pour
justine de produire ce qui était prévu
et petits pois et des haricots verts il
faudra en plus racheter une serre mais
le prix des matériaux a doublé la
situation est très tendue pour les
maraîchers et la filière est en
difficulté on voudrait être
indemnisées sur la perte de chiffre
d'affaires
donc on réclame une année blanche sur
les cultures sous abris pour tout les
serres qui ont été détruites et
et voilà on espère on espère que les
assureurs france y un geste pour annuler
tout ce qui est vétuste et sur les
serres qui ont été assurés et d'être
d'être remboursé au prix où on a payé
nos serres parce que là la situation est
vraiment catastrophique
une situation catastrophique qui peut
faire craindre l'arrêt de certaines
exploitations maraîchères
le vent qui peut causer aussi des débats
dans le val d'oise la majorité
départementale s'opposent au projet
d'installation d'éoliennes sur son
territoire vingt sites sont concernés
les éoliennes sont devenu depuis
quelques années un sujet polémique en
france entre objectifs climatiques
nuisances et impact sur l'environnement
le vent semble tourner comme nous le
montre ce sujet de michael joly pour
vyas 95
herblay la scène sont ils et derrière
côté yvelines bientôt peut être des
éoliennes une possibilité étudiée par la
préfecture de région qui vient d'envoyer
aux communautés de communes et aux
départements
une carte provisoire des zones qui
pourraient accueillir des éoliennes loin
de séduire le maire de la ville on
essaye de préserver des espaces naturels
et le peu d'espacés naturels qui nous
reste on ne veut pas que ça soit détruit
par par des éoliennes je ne suis même
pas informés que qui veulent mettre des
éoliennes des zones dans une vingtaine
de communes du département ont été
identifiés par la préfecture de région
comme pouvant accueillir des éoliennes
des implantations toutes rejetées par le
conseil départemental qui a rendu un
avis défavorable
c'est pas simplement qu'on ne veut pas
c'est qu'on démontre que soit des
bâtiments patrimoniaux des projets
peuvent être fortement impacté comme
j'ai dit d'urbanisme développement
économique de protection du patrimoine
comme la forêt
du val d'oise la forêt de pierrelaye
bessancourt on ne peut pas implanter sur
ces sites des parcs d'éoliennes un avis
pas partagée par l'opposition de gauche
et écologistes qui souhaitent des études
plus approfondies
nous sommes surpris de voir que la
majorité du conseil départemental vote
contre cet avis
sachant que effectivement il faut quand
même aller regarder d'un peu plus près
enfin moi ce que je comprends de cette
position c'est une position de principe
anti éoliennes en 2012 une précédente
carte avait été présentée par la
préfecture de région elle avait déjà
fait l'objet d'une levée de boucliers et
anne hidalgo était l'invité de
l'émission politique face aux
territoires sur tv5 monde ce jeudi la
candidate socialiste en grande
difficulté dans les sondages a notamment
évoqué son rapport au territoire en tant
que maire de paris alors est-ce un
handicap pour elle dans cette campagne
d'être à la tête de la première ville de
france écoutez sa réponse anne hidalgo
vous êtes la maire de paris dans un pays
très centralisé comment est ce que vous
allez prendre en compte l'extraordinaire
diversité des territoires français parce
que c'est aussi ça une lune une des
chances de la france cette diversité
mais comment est elle prise en compte
par vous-même dans cette campagne être
maire de paris c'est quoi c'est être
maire d'une ville la capitale de la
france certes mais qui a conquis sa
liberté et qui a conquis son pouvoir le
pouvoir des citoyens de paris face au
pouvoir central donc moi la
décentralisation et le fait que les
territoires doivent plus leurs cornes
préfon aujourd'hui alors il réforme une
grande réforme de la décentralisation
évidemment parce que emmanuel macron a
été un monarque républicain il a décidé
de tout tout seul tout le temps y
compris pendant la crise sanitaire donc
donné on n'a rien de région de donner
des moyens non donner des moyens à
toutes les communes aux régions aux
départements plus de le voir bien sûr
parce qu'aujourd'hui vous savez l'état
ne compense même pas les transferts de
compétences qui l'a fait vis-à-vis des
départements ou des communes et donc il
faut absolument si on veut une
efficacité de l'action publique et des
services publics il faut passer par la
proximité donc j'engagerai une très très
grande étape de décentralisation
et vous retrouve évidemment face aux
territoires avec anne hidalgo en repli
sur les sites internet de tv5monde de
ouest france de nice matin et de la
montagne
quand le leader mondial du luxe investi
dans les territoires louis vuitton vient
d'inaugurer deux nouveaux ateliers de
maroquinerie à vendôme dans le loir et
cher la stratégie du groupe de bernard
arnault vise à développer la production
en france avec des centaines d'emplois à
la clé une initiative saluée par le
ministre des l'économie bruno le maire
qui a fait le déplacement pour
l'occasion regardez ce reportage de
christophe rigaud
c'est dans cet immense bâtiment de verre
de 6500 mètres carrés que louis vuitton
vient d'installer un de ces deux
nouveaux ateliers à vendôme
150 maroquinier il confectionne les
célèbres sacs du numéro un mondial du
luxe pour l'événement les équipes de
lvmh à les convier des journalistes du
monde entier
s'installer ici à une heure de paris est
un choix assumé par le président du
groupe bernard arnault pour renforcer
l'ancrage de sa fabrication en france
stratégie les implantations de but on
sait de s'implanter
dans des régions qui sont agréables
vivre
lesquels ont
le créer de l'emploi est trouvé
un environnement propice au
développement de nos entreprises
industries
un projet de reconquête industrielle
encouragés par le ministre de l'économie
qui avaient fait le déplacement à
vendôme pour amener la part de
l'industrie dans la richesse nationale
française de 12 à 13% à peu près
aujourd'hui à 20% dans les prochaines
années ça doit être ça notre objectif il
faut se fixer des objectifs chiffrés que
l'industrie redevienne une part
importante de notre richesse nationale
ici en france la création de deux
nouveaux ateliers de fabrication ce sont
aussi des emplois à la clé des postes
occupés pour la plupart par des salariés
en reconversion
cette affaire tevez dois être ici
atypique on vient pas du tout la
maroquinerie et donner l'opportunité de
de la formation emploi c'est flatteur
porter de luxe et de prestige dont
le second atelier vuitton est installé
dans un ancien monastère du 11e siècle
en plein coeur de vendôme on y travaille
des qr spéciaux et exotiques à terme ce
sont 500 emplois qui seront créés sur
les deux sites de production
dans le reste de l'actualité la suite
des vacances d'hiver et au delà des
stations de ski qui profite de la fin
des restrictions liées aux comics 19
c'est toutes les régions qui salue le
retour en force des vacanciers à la can
où vous allez le voir dans le sud ouest
malgré une météo parfois capricieuse
le bilan devrait être positif agathe
bilstein pour tv7 la chaîne du groupe
sud ouest
cinq petits degrés matinaux une légère
brise mais un grand soleil en ce samedi
matin lacanau se réveille doucement et
les premiers vacanciers on profite déjà
il n'y a pas beaucoup de monde c'est
bien il ya de la place sur la plage on
peut se promener voilà après on peut pas
se baigner encore parce qu il fait un
peu frais mais non c'est agréable
l'hiver on aime beaucoup venir l'hiver
là et la météo justement conditionnent
tout après une semaine de pluies les
terrasses se déploie à nouveau dans ce
magasin et écoles de surf tout est fin
prêt pour démarrer la saison va
commencer les cours mardi dernier donc
c'est assez tôt dans la saison mais on
sent qu'il commence à voir un peu
d'influencé avec le beau temps se soit
une période de l'année où le temps est
très important dans la fréquentation de
la station en fait mais là on espère
qu'avec la semaine qui arrive et les
vacances de de paris notamment en plus
avoir un peu plus de monde chez ce
glacier même constat avec la pluie pas
la peine de lever le rideau mais ce week
end tout commence on a la chance de
pouvoir ouvrir l'année et du coup c'est
un plus à lacanau il ya de plus en plus
de fréquentation on espère qu'on va
pouvoir travailler quand on est ouvert
et pierre on demande que ça l'optimisme
est donc de mise et ce malgré une légère
baisse du nombre de touristes la faute à
l'ouverture des stations de ski mais
pour l'office de tourisme ce n'est pas
une fin en soi l'année dernière on était
à 21,8 pour cent de taux de
fréquentation à l'établissement et cette
année on a 10 9% donc voilà où les
stations ont rouvert pourtant la baisse
est très faible la destination tire donc
malgré tout son épingle du jeu en
espérant que la situation économique
suivent bilan à la fin des vacances
scolaires
bilan positif aussi pour les
discothèques qui ont pu de nouveau
accueillir du public il ya un peu plus
d'une semaine un soulagement d'ailleurs
après plusieurs mois de fermeture dont a
profité également les thés dansants et
fidèles de sai dance floor été nombreux
à se retrouver dans les vosges le
bonheur des clients était communicatif
pour les propriétaires et les musiciens
de cet orchestre que vous allez voir
tous à avis bien sûr de pouvoir
retravailler et en même temps de conflit
leur chiffre d'affaires un sujet dans le
tempo de marie danielle rogowicz et de
denis le kent pour vosges télévision
il n'aurait manqué pour rien au monde
cette réouverture
et ce premier thé dansant de l'année
l'établissement était fermé depuis le 10
décembre pour cause de crise sanitaire
alors les fidèles n'ont pas boudé leur
plaisir
c'est plus une petite nation n'avait
plus haut prévu voilà un autre petit
échappatoire on ne l'avait plus et la
grâce à l'ouverture enfin on peut
revivre entre guillemets permet de
revoir du monde de bouger un peu son
camp j'ai faire plaisir on veut oublier
le coc vide alors le masque se fait rare
même s'ils restent aux commandes et le
pass vaccinale lui est toujours
obligatoire
annick et serge les propriétaires de la
croisée des rivales sont confiants si
les aides promises se font attendre il
leur faut un gonfleur chiffre d'affaires
qui a pâti de ces deux mois de fermeture
on espère que ça va dire qu'ils vont
nous laisser ouvert jusqu'à la fin
cela en
et quand même
ad si on était on savait pas quoi faire
on sait pas sur quel pied danser
les musiciens de l'orchestré est
également le sourire est plus que jamais
l envie de travailler car ces dernières
semaines ont été difficiles pour ces
intermittents du spectacle et que ça
reprenne comme avant avec une
soixantaine de dates dans l'année et
puis pas plus de 60 dates mais voilà et
puis qu'on tourne un peu dans gran thèse
comme on faisait d'habitude une centaine
de danseurs en milieu de semaine pour
une reprise c'est mieux que d'habitude
et de bonne augure
[Musique]
chaque
voilà de beaux sourires et de la joie
sur cette piste de danse qui contraste
avec les révélations faites il ya
quelques semaines sur les maisons de
retraite gérée par le groupe orpea
aujourd'hui c'est tout un système qui
est remise en cause quant à la prise en
charge de nos aînés à l'usso dans la
sarthe des personnes âgées ont décidé de
vivre autrement grâce au béguinage vous
allez le voir dix neuf logements ont été
construits inauguré en septembre 2021 et
depuis le succès de ce mode de vie qui
rime entre solidarité et indépendance
est totale les explications avec diane
le moisson pour lmt sartre sur place
15 heures au béguinage de l'usso seller
de l'activité au programme aujourd'hui
pâtisserie jeux de société et brun cause
est le mauvais chemin du double voire
après j'ai mangé haute lisse qu'une
berline vient là et d'argent de l'année
je le mords oui
cherchez un logement de plain pied puis
bail sur mon équipe qu'on n'est pas tout
seul tout en étant indépendant anne
marie est arrivée ici au début mars et
elle s'y plaît beaucoup au qg elle
dispose de 55 m² parfait compromis entre
maisons individuelles et pas chacun dans
son petit logement chacun est libre de
ses mouvements mais en même temps il
participe à la vie quotidienne du
béguinage donc la bienveillance
l'autonomie le béguinage un concept peu
répandu qui est venu à l'idée de robert
renard ancien maire de l'usso alors
qu'il venait constater le décès d'une de
ses administrés tombé à quelques mètres
seulement de son logement c'est quand
même plus sécurisant de demeurer comme
ça dans un
lotissement de personnes âgées et puis
la même et pourtant ils étaient en
couple mais ça n'a pas empêché qu'elle
soit morte dans la cour je serai j'ai
trouvé ça inadmissible
comprise dans la prestation des navettes
sncf permettent aux locataires de se
rendre dans les commerces et services
lancé voilà un an la totalité des dix
neuf logements et pourvus mais il est
possible de se mettre sur liste
d'attenté seul impératif être âgées ou
handicapées et faire une demande de
logement sociaux
direction la martinique à présent dans
ce grand jt des territoires dans
quelques mois un projet de loi rendra
obligatoire l'adressage dans toutes les
villes de france or sur l'île des
caraïbes il n'est pas rare de trouver
encore des rues sans nom ni même de
numéros a ajout pas bouillon le maire a
décidé d'intégrer les habitants dans la
consultation qui vise à régler le
problème dans cette commune une seule
rue est nommé pour l'instant les
explications de jean marc d'abreu pour
via tv martinique
la rue il manie et marie-louise la seule
et unique rue d'anjou pas bouillon dans
cette commune même la rue de la mairie
d'un panneau une singularité qui
s'explique par la géographie
du bon fait que
nous avons plutôt de karachi résultat le
travail des services publics peut être
compliqué rosette 25 ans d'expérience
dans la distribution du courrier connaît
sa tournée sur le bout des doigts ses
origines luc lacaune
mais l'absence de nom de rue peut
parfois compliqué sa tâche la difficulté
qu'on a ici c'est d'efforts des fois ça
arrive à la résidence la fontaine et a
pas de numéro dans ces conditions la
possible ne peut pas être remplacé au
pied levé s'avérer qui a beaucoup de
gars qui peut avoir des homonymies donc
on obligé de les former pendant trois
semaines ça nous arrive pour soit faite
à des personnes qui débarquent sur la
commune et qui
ne font pas donc de raccordement postal
on ne sait pas c'est qui la personne
habite et les noms n'apparaissent pas
sur les boîtes aux lettres enveloppes la
compagne de nomination de rue lancé par
la commune devrait faciliter la tâche
des postiers mais aussi des autres
services publics comme les secours
après la compétition le retour à la
maison pour les athlètes qui ont
participé aux jeux olympiques d'hiver de
pékin la principauté de monaco attendait
notamment avec impatience le retour de
ses bober rudy rinaldi son frère anthony
et bourhis va ils sont passés tout
proche de l'exploit avec leur bobsleigh
longtemps en course pour un podium ils
se sont finalement classés 6e de
l'épreuve en duo le meilleur résultat de
toute l'histoire olympique monégasque
alors accueillies pour leur retour par
leurs familles et amis il jonglait entre
joie et regrets réaction au micro de
vanessa deux signé de jean alexandre
dordé ça fait du bien est à la maison on
sent un peu là les gens qui sont sur le
côté ça nous fait du bien de revoir ça
qu'on était pas mal soutenus pendant
en cette compétition et d'être ici pour
partager des moments comme ça avec les
gens qui nous ont suivi c'est vraiment
super les gens m'ont vu un peu déçu
après la compétition c'est vrai que ils
comprennent pas que
on nous a enfin le fait d'avoir loupé un
peu c'est le quatrième manche jamais un
peu
voler ses deux minutes de bonheur où on
aurait pu croire à une certaine à une
potentielle médaille de bronze donc
c'est vrai que j'avais besoin de temps
pour réaliser ça et je commence tout
doucement à le faire avec les gens aussi
qui sont là qui nous entourent ça me
ferait du bien elle n'est pas encore une
épreuve olympique mais surtout une
passion la nage en monopalme cette
activité notamment pratiqué par aurore
du côté de toulouse dans la grenouille
locale aurore alias à quoi tu as se
définit comme une artiste sirène comme
vous le voyez sur ces images de matisse
tu gardes du journal la dépêche du midi
nos partenaires dans l'eau elles
assurent le spectacle avec son costume
sa perruque et son apparence de sirène
tout droit sortie d'un studio de disney
cette sirène toulousaine qui a réussi à
faire de son rêve une réalité
puisqu'elle s'est déjà produit dans des
clips vidéo notin
restons à l'eau dans ce journal et dans
le sud ouest où a été dévoilée récemment
le premier catamaran de plongée 100%
électrique une prouesse technologique
qui permettra bien sûr de réduire
l'impact environnemental de cette
pratique et qui repose sur la volonté
d'un seul homme simon billeau le
responsable d'un club de plongée dans
les pyrénées-orientales alice et marty
de l'aa d'action de via occitane il a
rencontré lors de la première sortie du
bateau au regard des
premiers bains pour ce catamaran de
plongée 100% électrique unique en france
c'est le pari fou que s'est lancé simon
gérant d'un centre de plongée éco
responsable chaque année il fait tout
pour améliorer ses pratiques afin d'être
plus respectueux de l'environnement
j'essaye tout le temps de réfléchir de
dire comment on pourrait faire mieux et
puis un moment j'avais mon bateau on va
dire que je suis arrivé un peu au bout
de la réflexion sur ce bateau là et il y
avait ces deux moteurs diesel
qui font du bruit qu'ils font de fumée
que c'est du gasoil qu'il ya toutes les
maintenances avec lui la change
régulièrement pour les filtres qu'il
faut changer et je me suis dit faut les
enlever ses moteurs donc faut partir sur
l'électrique donc là j'ai commencé à
faire des petits calculs et bien là en
fait si c'est possible bâton moteur
batterie électronique tout je suis à 125
mille euros sachant qu'on va dire que le
moindre bateau de
de plongée neuf avec la motorisation
entre 150 et 200 euros et après deux ans
de travail le catamaran est à l'eau à
vitesse maximale il a une autonomie de
2h rechargeable par des panneaux
solaires dès le mois de mai qu'il pourra
accueillir à chaque sortie une douzaine
de personnes
une autre démarche écologique à
l'honneur dans cette édition dans les
yvelines l'entreprise est née 10 fait
appel désormais aux forces de la nature
et à la traction animale pour certaines
de ces opérations là où les camions
polluer abîme les sols et bien
l'entreprise travaille avec des chevaux
de trait une solution écologique et
respectueuse de l'environnement déployés
récemment pour traîner des poteaux en
béton difficile d'accès à ce sujet de
ces lignes charles de tv 78 la chaîne
des yvelines
voici nina et farceur et à leur allure
athlétique on peut deviner que ces
chevaux de trait ne sont pas venus ici
pour gambader dans les prés au contraire
ils ont été missionnés pendant deux
jours par l'entreprise et ne disent leur
objectif tracts et huit poteaux en béton
jusqu'à une zone de dépôt ou en camion
prendra le relais les chevaux donc on
encolure avec un collier qui les
préserve de tout de tout effort de toute
difficulté en fait on met un on met les
poteaux béton sur un attelage vont
rechercher les poteaux béton et les
ramènent jusqu'à un endroit de stockage
temporaire avant qu'on les achemine vers
un centre de recyclage conforme là on
peut le voir le il ya eu beaucoup d'eau
il y avait des verts à certains endroits
il ya peu de passage à d'autres et donc
bah là à utiliser les chevaux qui sont
très maniable et qui eux peuvent marcher
facilement aînés 10 a fait appel à
sabots sur terre une entreprise normande
dirigé par louise brieuc qui intervient
dans toute la france depuis 2010 9 cette
passionnée d'équitation grèce elle-même
ses chevaux qui lui obéissent au doigt
et à l'oeil quand je tire comme ça c'est
gauche voilà ma jument elle donne la
tête et quand je fais des plus des
petits lacs ou cetc droite puis
passionné de chevaux depuis mes 10 ans
et j'ai fait des études j'ai trente
trois ans et
découvert la traction animale à mes 27
ans par là je cherchais à travailler
avec avec les chevaux mais pas me
concentrer uniquement sur eux faire
faire quelque chose avec pratique et
écologique cette méthode ancienne fait
son grand retour pour des questions
essentiellement environnementales les
chevaux il ya moins nuisances sonores il
ya moins de nuisances en termes de co2
effectivement l'empreinte carbone et
maîtrisez également des enjeux de
biodiversité
parce que si on était en effet
intervenir des engins soient plus créé
des ornières dans ce terrain très beau
très beau et très marécageux première à
déployer cette pratique dans les
yvelines est né dix espère que d'autres
projets comme celui-ci émergeront allez
on remonte dans le temps pour terminer
ce journal plume buvard encre certains
d'entre vous se rappellent sûrement de
ces objets essentiels à l'apprentissage
du français dans l'aube une dictée à
l'ancienne était organisé il ya quelques
jours un rendez vous devenu traditionnel
pour célébrer les mots l'orthographe et
la grammaire dans la commune de flühli
ni un reportage sans faute d'action de
canal32
douzième de vie pour donner une bouffée
de nostalgie c'est un sans faute la 9e
édition de la dictée de fellini organisé
par l'association objectif patrimoine
était de retour ce dimanche dans
l'étonnant village de 50 habitants tel
village d'enseignante et villages
instituteurs donc on était assez
favorable à l'écriture à la lecture donc
on a convenu qu une dictée pouvait être
quelque chose à la faute culturel
convivial est effectivement vu le succès
que nous avons régulièrement on pense
qu'on était bien dans le dans les clous
pour l'exercice l'association fournit la
plume sergent major le buvard l'encrier
et même la feuille avec la frise en bas
de page les souvenirs de surgissent là
ça va être
porte plume le blizzard en enfance au
cours de l'après-midi deux dictées sont
proposés plutôt facile de l'aveu des
participants elles ont été choisies par
les membres de l'association a le grand
plaisir des seniors 50 ans les prépare
ça nous permet de nous réunir donné ce
que tel de choisir le plaisir des mots
le plaisir de la grammaire font partie
du jeu l'édition 2022 a regroupé 45
participants qui ont usé leurs fonds de
culottes sur les bancs de l'école est
également en se frottant à des exercices
de français ça tout était un plaisir en
fait donc c'est pour ça qu'ils
effectivement après dès lors que c'est
un plaisir
les choses sont beaucoup plus faciles
les fonds récoltés par la participation
à la dictée permettent d'aider la mairie
de flühli ni à financer la restauration
de son patrimoine comme celle de la
salle de classe fermée depuis 1971 est
ouverte grâce à ce rendez vous dédié à
l'orthographe
voilà c'est la fin de ce grand jt des
territoires merci de nous avoir suivi on
se retrouve très vite pour une prochaine
édition au revoir à tous
[Musique]